okay here we go
thank you so much for coming what an
amazing turnout
my name is leslie knope i am the deputy
director of the parks and recreation
department
and tonight we're going to be taking
some of your questions as
hello we're having a meeting in here
does anybody have any questions about
permits we don't need palaces
the ideas are what shine in our meetings
what are you some kind of [ __ ]
why don't you have hand dryers in the
park bathrooms they're so much more
sanitary than paper towels
anyone knows that my dog went to one of
your parks and ate another dog's feces
and i am going to sue you for that
how do you like it no how do you like
that
now imagine you're holding coffee with
the government shut down who's gonna
stop al-qaeda
one thing at a time i don't like
obscenities just as much as you don't
like oh it drives me crazy i have kids
right but i've got my little
three-year-old i'm going through the
park and someone's like
hey mike the guys you my
head these people are members of a
community that care about where they
live
so what i hear when i'm being yelled at
is
people caring loudly at me
nutrium's energy bars are just
absolutely loaded with high fructose
corn syrup and fatty oils and any way
you slice it they're just
extremely unhealthy for you leslie needs
to butt out
the whole point of this country is if
you want to eat garbage
balloon up to 600 pounds and i have a
heart attack at 43
you can you are free to do so to me
that's beautiful any questions
if sugar's so bad how come jesus made it
taste so good
uh yes but isn't all food bad for you
i've been eating lasagna and muffins
every day of my life for 40 years and i
feel terrible
right what's so bad about corn syrup
it's natural
corn's a fruit syrup comes from a bush
oh boy
how do we know you're really a nurse i
am i promise i work at st
joe's well the point is my friend thinks
you're cute
give me your number so he can have it
yeah that's not
gonna happen can i have your email
address i just got on aol
no i think we ought to throw those bars
out and eat ham and mayonnaise
sandwiches that's not a good idea
ham and mayonnaise
so that's what today's forum is for
we're gonna hear suggestions from
everyone and then whichever items we
generally agree on will go into the time
capsule
please remember this is a government
project so we need to refrain from
corporate promotion and religious items
who'd like to start i think we should
put in the bible
great okay anyone else yeah if we put a
tax on soda i mean what's next
income sir you don't pay your income tax
whether or not i pay income taxes none
of the government's business
no well yeah no actually it is well you
don't know my name or
what i look like so good luck finding me
anyone else
anyone this gentleman wants to say
something
no i don't come on mel you're always up
in arms about something no i'm not
i'm not always up in arms about
something here we go that's the spirit
talk to me about what's bothering you
okay are there any more recommendations
for new games at the rec center
my daughter she loves shoots and ladders
oh come
on there is no strategy to shoots and
ladders it's just luck
my daughter's five well your daughter is
an idiot her daughter is an idiot
her daughter is an idiot her daughter
isn't it it's the only park in our
neighborhood i mean where are my kids
supposed to play the rock quarry
there's rocks in there why don't we just
set fire to the fats you know set it
ablaze
that's arson well let's leave that up to
lawyers point is it would work
why don't we build a fence around their
fence
why it would give us two fences
so if they needed to get to their fence
for maintenance and whatnot
their pants might get caught let the
filibustering begin
i would now like to share some ideas i
have for j.j abrams
seventh chapter in the star wars saga
panned down from the twin sons
of tatooine we are now close on the
mouth of the sarlacc pit
after a beat the gloved mandalorian
armor
gauntlet of boba fett grabs onto the
sand outside the sarlacc pit
and the feared bounty hunter pulls
himself
from the maw of the sand beast i think
we should tax
all bad things like racism
and women's vaginas we're not taxing
anyone's genitals what the hell are we
doing here
come on boys
hello can everyone hear me okay no no no
okay great i'm councilwoman leslie knope
and today we are here to talk about safe
sex
i know this is a personal question but
how many of you out there are sexually
active
oh my i have two partners often at the
same time
wow thank you does anyone know what we
risk
when we have unprotected sex hardest
things
broken yeah on top of you yes but
the truth is the greatest risk you face
is sexually transmitted diseases
are these old people really having sex
with each other yeah what did you think
they were doing i don't i don't we're
just talking about it
oh
best way to prevent them is to use
protection well that's all
fine and good but what if the banana is
soft and mushy
and dog legs sharply to the left oh if
he holds the reality gem
that means he can jump from different
realities this
will be our link to the marvel universe
from the star wars universe
all taxation is theft if the government
can tax me i can
i can do this grover give that woman her
purse back
there's a lot of pill bottles in here
okay imagine those two
going up against robot chewbacca because
that's gonna happen after a beat
luke says darth vader was my father but
ben kenobi was my master
and he cuts hannah blechter in half okay
my name is ron
you don't need to know my last name
whoever wants to talk go ahead and we'll
be out of here in a tight 15.
i found a sandwich in one of your parks
and i want to know
why it didn't have mayonnaise what's so
funny
oh yeah i don't think kids should be
allowed on the playground equipment
okay we've been over this if you're
worried about swine flu
use hand sanitizer i'm not worried about
swine flu i already have the swine flu
i'm worried about the turtle flu
turtle flu turtle food
turtle flu is this gonna be a topless
park
i don't think there are topless parks
well let's build the first one
and be heroes if this is going to be a
topless park i won't sign your petition
if she's going to the topless park i'm
not signed into the topless park
petition
you know i take that back i'm still in
what's up i'm harris
yeah yeah forget whatever that uh pawnee
commons is i'm with that pervert
topless park topless park topless park
topless park bjorn lorpis of the pawnee
lerpus family
they were supposed to be a paunch burger
and there's a lot next to my house
and then you strip my freedom by putting
a park there now if i want to start my
day off with a triple decker pancake
breakfast pizza
i gotta go to one that's 10 minutes away
and that makes me 20 minutes late to
work every day
i work at home have you ever considered
not eating that for breakfast i'll never
consider that school is out in two weeks
what am i going to do with my kids all
day keep them in my house
where i live i think the slogan should
be pawnee
home of crackers the oranges goldfish in
indiana
okey dokey no let me write it down who
even needs a slogan well now that is an
interesting point
no that's my slogan idea who even needs
a slogan and then a big picture of me
flipping everybody off look we don't
know what the world is going to be like
in 50 years we
we could all have been wiped out from
disease or the flu
so what's your suggestion i don't know
i'm just scared my idea for a slogan
is when you're here then you're home
well that's lovely i actually had it
printed up so we could see what it would
look like
oh you um there's that's that's spelled
wrong that should be
then t-h-e-n stay strong let them work
it out
and trust larry trust larry are you even
listening to yourself i like that slogan
a lot
but you made a little mistake there
she's gonna
she's gonna work it out you're right
back off
you're misspelled wrong it should be
y-o-u-r
oops i didn't catch it thank you my
grandmother lived in pawnee for 60 years
and
i want to put her ashes in the time
capsule my cat
turnip was the greatest cat ever and i'd
like to put his ashes in the time
capsule
for the last time and i won't say this
again
there will be no human or feline ashes
in either one of the time capsules
except for
turnip except for turnips no
chanting can we see the condom
demonstration again
because i don't know where lou has been
well i i i wish i i
i could but i
i'll screw it okay here this is a penis
right you put a condom on it and you
pull the tip like this and you roll it
all the way down the penis
tell you what condoms for everybody who
wants them
you